you're there but that's not bad you're
there which is not bad yet
[Music]
hello and welcome to
a FNAF fan game I am peeking behind the
curtains
I mean
it doesn't look too terrible
I see some empty suits to the right I
see some kind of Bonnie playing banjo up
on the stage I hear the lovely sounds of
people being entertained and children
being happy and all is well in the world
oh cool Heyday
hey it's like the Left 4 Dead menu
that's cool but yes hello to the return
to bloody nights
um
Five Nights at Freddy's fan game hey
Henry hi William it's good to hear your
voice again how have you been
good it's been a bit stressful to be
honest but just busy with the new
animatronic project
it's going really well and um I'm
excited to finally open up my own
restaurant I see well we've had a pretty
good run with Freddy Fazbear's Pizza so
far it's been doing really well
yeah I've heard I'm actually a bit
jealous to be honest
I really want my place to be as
successful if not more successful than
Freddy's
I'm sure it will be William you've put a
lot of work into this thanks I really
hope so
that's great to hear I'm sure it'll be a
success but I wanted to talk with you
about something important sure what is
it I've been reading about some
incidences at other restaurants where
animatronics have been malfunctioning
and causing harm to visitors
I want to make sure that our
establishments are safe for everyone who
comes through our doors
and especially yours too
I understand your concerns
rest assured I'm being extremely careful
with the programming and Engineering of
the animatronics
safety is my top priority
I still want you to take your time with
the project
rushing things could lead to mistakes
I promise I won't rush anything
I want this restaurant to be just as
perfect as you do but I do need to move
quickly if we're going to open until no
but please keep safety in mind Above All
Else
I don't want any accidents or injuries
to happen
I understand Henry you can trust me to
handle everything properly
is there anything else you wanted to
talk about
no that's all for now just keep me
updated on the progress of the project
okay
will do Henry talk to you soon
take care William
oh yes that all seems fine and lovely
and I'm sure that it is going as
swimmingly as projected and there will
be no incidents because they're never
more
spare entertainment
Bears your dreams or so I hope
because many things are currently
happening and I can't personally be
present everywhere I leave you these
pre-recorded messages to cover any
questions you may have and respond to
any incidents that may occur during your
night shift Adventure
you might be asking yourself waffle just
how difficult is this job what wasn't
that phone book of a contract I just
signed today am I in danger let me
answer those questions with a question
who wants to earn some money that's
right
all for just sitting and waiting in a
well protected room with a comfortable
office chair and a cup of
coffee's been sitting around and not
being able to pay your bills isn't it
yeah a little bit we're not cheap here
at Fazbear entertainment we'll pay you a
cool 110 bucks per week which I know is
a lot so just don't go and spend all of
it on something frivolous like you
usually do okay we value and take care
of all our staff and I want to inform
you that our equipment here is very damn
expensive it's top of the line stuff
we've had our Fair Sheriff Knuckleheads
trying to break in at night so you
better keep those beepers peeled and
glued to that monitor on your desk don't
you dare smudge it up or you'll be
cleaning it with your own toothbrush
if anything happens to our property then
it is your responsibility your job here
is very important and if you can finish
this week without any problems you'll be
rewarded with a voucher for some of our
delicious pizzas trust me it's worth it
well
okay sounds good
action but until then just sit tight and
don't touch anything you don't need to
if anything goes wrong we'll know
exactly who to blame just sit tight keep
your eyes peeled and don't make me
regret hiring you I don't want to be the
one responsible for messing things up
around here
uh all right listen up we need to talk
about your safety when we need to talk
about it now now why in front of you
you'll see a fancy surveillance system
that'll let you keep an eye on
everything happening in this place okay
when I say everything I mean everything
no slacking off on the job or you'll
have a mean answer to okay now those
mechanical doors on your left and right
might look like something out of a
sci-fi movie but they're not toys
or you'll be singing soprano for the
next week and trust me I don't want to
be paying for any medical bills
Insurance
because once you step foot in this place
you're on your own ah if things go south
you're not getting a dime out of me
one more thing if you notice your vision
getting blurry or your eyes begin to
water and burn don't worry that's just a
side effect of working in this
environment it persists for a week start
worrying and go see your personal doctor
okay we're all in this together
um
the spare and his best friend spring
Bonnie the guitarist these two have been
entertaining children in this town for
years and now they're getting an upgrade
after we renovated the entire place we
added some great new features including
making them more interactive with our
customers and staff during the day okay
but since we have so much to do and so
little time we decided to test some of
the features during your night shift
okay so if you see them wandering around
the pizzeria through the cameras do
yourself a favor and just let those
handsome Devils go about their business
here's what you have to do when those
animatronics start lurking near your
office shut the door and keep them out
during the day those guys will pop up in
your office to say hello to the security
guard like they're your best butts
that's part of the entertainment you
know okay okay kid I gotta go handle my
own business now and
let's get this night shift started and
hope for the best
just remember you could be working in a
morgue instead so have some fun enjoy
the ambience and keep your hands off
those animatronics most importantly stay
alert we don't want any accidents
happening on our watch do we
okay
we'll need it see you tomorrow so how's
my employer aren't you responsible for
getting me insurance and also why are
there so much information about missing
children and also why is there a William
Afton diploma is that who I am
is that what you think I am
I'm kind of William
some kind of Afton
I know I saw one over here before
oh
well that doesn't sound good
but I don't see anything
so it couldn't possibly be bad
it's already wood
I
could hi there you are
ah you're moving
are these live video feeds or what
it's fine so far Okay so
[Music]
it was fine
where did you go
well why probably not good
should I worry about that
I do love that door that is delightful
well I
looking down
so
again I don't know if that's
oh two three wait oh two three nine five
six
what what
what what what what what what
[Music]
uh-huh
okay
yeah what am I oh
ah
wow
oh god oh boy
[Music]
oh okay I can do this I got this I gotta
admit this is uh
this is one of the cooler mini games in
these uh
little excursions
what
[Music]
stuff
okay
[Music]
oh come on am I Really Gonna just keep
doing this probably
[Music]
okay okay
oh so close why did I try to slide that
out probably would have been fine
no
oh what what what the frick what what
the what
[Music]
whoa my God what am I doing what no how
oh God
no how I was right there I had that ah I
failed so much with this I'm gonna give
this one more try if I don't get it I'm
just gonna move on because I'm not here
for this I'm here for the Freddy
experience
[Music]
all right that's it I'm not here for
this I'm not here for that I'm not I'm
not here for that that's not why I'm
here all right so I'm here to play this
game about the phenafening and
eventually maybe I'll get to the world
forever
Fazbear entertainment ah
blessed silence you just need to hit the
tape recorder it was so simple all along
okay so let's get an idea of what we're
dealing with I know I lost a few hours
listening to that message the first time
and then I went into a mini game which I
didn't even understand why I don't even
remember
I don't even remember what the number is
so someone's gonna have to go back and
remind me of that if I need to beat
those again which I'm sure that I will
at some point down the road just not
right now
is not in the immediate now I built up
some skills I got better at it so I'm
sure that I'll be able to beat it
eventually if I bash my head against the
wall enough but until then I'm going to
continue
so we got some squonkies
definitely plenty of squonkies out there
two doors and then this weird look back
which
I can't see anything in the back so I
don't even know what I'm supposed to be
looking back to
it is nice that I can hide the mini I'm
gonna pee your pants but it looks a very
similar layout to most of these uh
fazbearer locations
but he does seem fairly basic in that
there's two animatronics for now I'm
sure I'm sure there'll be more
it's two or maybe it is just two no
[Music]
no
just two
maybe nothing yet though
1979 is the degree of 79 still missing
Lost Child Susie
Hurricane Valley
well that's something
and all this something
you know the Ambiance is good that's for
sure
uh moving door can cause serious injury
keep clear door can move at any time
without prior warning do not let
children near the door yeah that seems
like basic rules
what what
why
what is that
okay I think that's Bonnie moving
I think
so Bonnie's on the prowl
as far as I can tell
but no one's nearby just yet so I'm good
for now and I don't think I have to keep
staring at that
there's no lights to check if they're at
the doors why
hi there buddy oh
you're breathing I don't know why
a little unsettling but
you do you 3 A.M so I'm about where I
was before which is nice
there's not more of you are there
you better not be
it's that same thing when you first get
into a game you just have no idea what
all the sounds are and they just
resonate all around you doing God knows
what
but I'm gonna operate under the
assumption that all those noises are
just a bunch of nothing
and I need not worry
oh they're seem content to be stuck
right there which is good for me
4 AM
it's gonna be one of those easy nights
I say with confidence
[Music]
up he's on the move
ah there you are
well Freddy seems content to stay there
but if I keep my eye on you I think I'm
gonna be a little bit better off
Freddie's still stuck there which is
good
where'd you go anyway
5 a.m and still no trouble
so far so good
I might make it out of this night
without even encountering either of them
which would be good
[Music]
a lot of noises I think I must get on by
and what's even better it's June 27th
which means that tomorrow is my birthday
so hopefully I don't die on my birthday
that would be really depressing hip hip
hooray what a good work day can I go
home
can I go home now there we go thank you
what an easy day
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks
oh
oh am I oh why am I what kind of what
kind of scanning weird crossbow ass
thing is this
hey you better watch yourself I'm gonna
scan your tum tum you better not move
you better not move nothing I got some
wiggle waggles
[Music]
I don't know what that was oh look at
this goofy nerd look at that goofy nerd
all right
whatever hey William how's the progress
of the new location coming hey Henry
everything's going well the animatronics
are on track and I'm confident about
meeting our opening date that's good to
hear however I need to emphasize that
safety is our top priority I said this
so much Henry we can't afford any
mistakes pressure to meet the deadline
might cause you to rush things I
understand your concern but rest assured
that safety is always my top priority
I know what I'm doing and I won't take
any unnecessary risks
I hope so but I've been hearing some
worries from others that your methods of
work could lead to some problems they're
also worried that your recent divorce
might affect your judgment
my personal life has nothing to do with
my work
as for my methods they have always
worked in the past and will work now
I have everything under control
I see just remember that I'm here to
support you and the company
if you need any help or advice don't
hesitate to ask
thank you for your offer but I've got it
covered
I'll keep you updated on the progress
please do and keep in mind that safety
comes first oh my God I get it any
injuries or accidents safety comes first
I heard you
safety safety everyone is safe here
there's no one in danger least of all me
and then second least of all the
children
but there's no danger across the board
so nothing to be worried about why would
you be worried I'm not worried and I'm
looking down
the job you seem to have everything
under control don't you that's what I
like to see so you can handle themselves
I'll keep it short and only tell you
what is absolutely necessary
the main two animatronics also have a
second functionality that'll blow your
mind you can actually wear them like a
costume now I know what you're thinking
waffle that sounds like the greatest
thing ever but hold your horses for a
second these newer models aren't quite
perfected yet they've got a bit of a
if you're not careful they could crush
your chest and you'll bleed out until
the dawn what trust me man I gotta I
gotta I gotta go one second I hope
nothing terrible happens while I'm away
poor guy ended up in a hospital bed with
his legs crushed it's tragic but
informative
snow that if something goes wrong it's
on you
actually don't even touch them we're not
taking any responsibility here so if we
find you the next morning dead inside of
one of our mascots don't come crying to
us you are informed and we are clean uh
yeah
true I don't know anyway a new mascot
was added to the cast recently and not
just any mascot mind you this one's
special
made solely by one of the founders
himself Henry Emily now I don't know
much about it but what I do know is that
it's been causing some trouble so much
so that we had to lock it up in your
office
but don't worry we've got a prize Corner
set up there and it's a win-win
situation for all of us right
okay
oh my God
where a puppet crept into a sleeping
man's mouth
don't worry we'll get through this we
always do
waste just keep an eye on those
animatronics and stay out of trouble
I'm always here for you what do you mean
crawling into man's mouth yeah I'm gonna
go get some should I I'll talk to you
tomorrow
goodbye what do you what do you mean
crawling into man's mouth what did I
miss everybody what did I miss
Dude tell me what I missed right is it
the thing about looking behind me oh
what do you mean crawling in a man's
mouth
what's gonna be crawling in a man's
mouth I'm a man
I have a mouth I missed something
vitally important I believe and uh
of a funny feeling I'm gonna regret it
well neither of them are on the move and
it is my birthday so
um
I assume that they're gonna go easy on
me and then I'm not gonna die horrible
death
probably
what is this about looking behind me
this
there's nothing behind me
is there oh oh oh oh oh
no Sonic no
no no
no
what do you mean is this the vitally
important information that I've missed
out on because holy crap I don't know
what that's about Freddy
what are you doing
I don't like you I don't like you I
don't like you I don't like you I don't
like you I don't like you why
what is happening
is something gonna be crawling
why
what is gonna be crawling
I don't
period I don't
well they're really not doing very much
I I feel like something more should be
happening but nothing more is happening
and I don't know why
I feel like usually at this point in the
game I'm like it's so easy and then I
die
why do you look like eyes why is all of
this terrible on me
is that Bonnie Bonnie
what do you mean squeak
what do you mean squonk
oh God hey what in the frick
oh
hi Freddy I think that's you why are you
so close
comfortable this is really uncomfortable
I got it man
I ain't too happy about this did you
know it's my birthday huh
oh
hi this is about these
it's years good
oh God where are you
hi
hello
good to see you
hi both of you wow that's great
that's great that's really close to my
this Zone though so oh you're gone oh oh
God oh God no
how long can I keep that
closed
huh where'd you go
huh
don't like it
okay I think it's clear
I I think I'm guessing
I don't really know
my God I don't like this what is that
sound there's a sound
hi there
squeaking
seems problematic
stop that wait stop that
oh
uh
generator heat is good and heated
um
so
why what does that mean
foreign
that's good the Donk usually means it's
okay
well that's not good okay but I think I
can wait until he's right nearby because
I gotta let the generator cool down
I think he'll be going
[Music]
[Applause]
so what was that about crawling down a
grown man's mouth
if I caught that right hey you better
watch yourself checking for vibes
what's going on here huh
I'm sensing something bad going on
inside that mouth
hope it's not you making those groaning
noises because this is gonna be really
uncomfortable as it is okay you're good
thank you for cooperating have a lovely
day
um yeah sure oh keep going why not
how are you doing today oh
Henry
I'm doing all right I wanted to touch
base with you about something
I heard that some of the employees saw a
preview of the new animatronics design
and
they were a bit concerned that they
looked a little too scary and robotic
what were your thoughts on that
well I can understand why they might
think that
but I assure you the final project will
be much more child friendly the
employees only saw a work in progress
and were still fine-tuning the details
I hope you're right William
we don't need any negative experiences
from our youngest Henry just why
I've been studying child psychology to
ensure that the animatronics Creator
positive and safe experience great
unconfident that we'll achieve that goal
great I believe my robots will be the
best around better than yours Henry I
trust your expertise in this area
on a personal note how are you holding
up with with the uh divorce proceedings
it's been a difficult time Henry
I won't lie about that
but I'm doing my best to keep my focus
on my work and my children the most
important thing to me but very separate
so was Charlotte for me she is my only
family
I just want you to remember that it's
okay for you to take some time to
yourself
you can't pour from an empty cup
don't forget to take a break and
recharge
thank you for the reminder
I appreciate your concern
I'll try to take care of myself as well
and my work too no problem William
we'll talk again soon
take care you too Henry I'll take care
of myself my work and my children all
very separate distinct things that have
nothing to do with one another
at all ever period end of discussion in
other words uh
greetings my dear employee
congratulations on making it to night
three the simple fact that you're here
listening to me means that you've made a
glorious contribution to Fazbear
entertainment on behalf of the fellow
behind myself as the CEO of the company
I want to thank you for your
participation and dedication to this job
we hope that we can count on you for
another week of your excellent service
unless you've got some Big Dreams you'll
Chase it after well you know so tell me
have you seen anything weird the past
couple of nights I don't know I want to
know every little detail going on in
this fine establishment if you didn't
report nothing this morning I'll assume
everything's all good speaking of which
have you ever wondered how this place
operates during the day despite all the
rumors and investigations it's actually
pretty great I mean I was taking a
stroll around here earlier and saw some
kids jumping into the ball pit and
having a blast they even pretended it
was a time machine kids these days
I tell you sometimes those kids have
more imagination in their pinkies than
most adults have in their whole bodies
it's a shame we lose that spark as we
get older damn shame entertainment is
all about bringing a little magic back
into our lives right and you're a
crucial part of making that happen so
it's the good work
I have a little something for you if
you're interested in earning an
additional twenty dollars uh-huh we're
recording some lines for the instruction
tapes regarding the spring lock
technology and I think you'd be perfect
for the job you got a great Voice kid
all right all you have to do is read
some text into a recording machine okay
sure you're compensated for your time
okay you don't gotta learn nothing fancy
just be the voice on the tapes we want
to send them to every Pizzeria that uses
new spring lock costumes how cool is
that that is so cool we need our new
assistant her name is Karen I'm just
going to tell you exactly what
do I do about that great
keep up the good work and keep on
keeping on until next time stay safe and
don't forget to check those cameras I'll
talk to you soon
oh oh okay so it's not a problem yet but
it will be a problem soon ah it's a
problem I I have a that's a problem
that's a problem
what why
is that the thing that's going to be
crawling down my throat Karen where's
Karen Karen
Karen wasn't there a thing about Karen
isn't Karen a thing I was way too early
wasn't I oh for oh frick oh frick
Frick oh frick uh frick
da frick
Frick hi okay pull up when the doors
open the door's open
are you not doing anything yet are you
just sitting there are you not doing
anything in that is that the threatening
pose my generator is gonna explode
oh man this is not good wait no
something happened who who did what
they both did they're both doing they're
doing right now
ah
perfect easy
practically too easy
what is that
Karen you Karen
Karen
hello
did I do that
I can't I keep accidentally doing that
because if you get even slightly low
like when you're going for these
it it'll drop the screen where where
where where where where where where
where where
are you
ah there you are
oh that doesn't seem good wait
what is sounds
where are you okay you're there but
that's not bad you're there which is not
bad yet
oh what is that
skeleton
what do you mean all right am I in that
one there I don't know what that was
supposed to be but uh that's a new
that's a new all right uh good this has
been the return to bloody nights I'll
probably play some more of this it's
pretty good it's got some Spooks um uh
but for all the talking that's going on
I seem to be missing some things so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out more Five Nights at Freddy's
content that I have Linked In the
description below or on my channel just
look up Five Nights at Freddy's
Markiplier or something like that you'll
find something thank you
let me know what you thought of this
down in the comments and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]